in Germany no Christmas is complete
without a Christmas tree but where
exactly did the tradition originated the
vine ox house in whose of northern
Germany is a museum devoted to the topic
of Christmas
it's run by Alex Paulson honza
you could say Christmas is a very German
holiday the first time a fir tree was
decorated with lights was in a
german-speaking region exactly where is
still a matter of debate we'll never
know for sure but there was an early
version of a Christmas tree in Silesia
the Germans tree of choice is the
Nordmann fur
grown in some 7,000 Christmas tree
plantations across the country and cut
down when they're 8 to 12 years old the
tree originally comes from the Caucasus
Mountains it's popular because it tends
to be straight its needles are
relatively soft and it doesn't shed too
much but it's less fragrant than the
other trees even so around 75% of German
Christmas trees are Nordmann firs
mattias Barton decorates Christmas trees
for companies and hotels it's supposed
to symbolize the birth of Jesus new life
in the world people would hang a tree
somewhere in the home to represent a
paradise tree or a tree of life these
ball Molina thought the Christmas tree
used to be considered a pagan tradition
only in the mid 19th century did the
custom become widespread ironically this
peaceful tradition began in war time
during the franco-prussian war of 1870
to 71 the Kaiser had small decorated
trees placed in hospitals and camps ease
the soldiers who survived the war then
introduced this as a custom once they
returned home
there have been Christmas trees and
homes ever since in my house I'd stacked
a foot in the beginning people would
decorate their trees not with ornaments
but with fruit and nuts but legend has
it that there came a time in the mid
19th century when glass blowers in Lucia
Thuringia could no longer afford these
treats so they started making glass
ornaments instead
glass blown Christmas ornaments are
still made the old-fashioned way in Laos
on the glass surface gets a coating of
silver to make them shiny auras
hand-painted this moon face was made
with a mold dating from 1910 a hundred
years ago Christmas decorations were
incredibly diverse and filigree that the
Talmud the craftsmen who made these
forms were meticulous and professional
they don't make Christmas ornaments like
that anymore and that's a pity but it
makes the old pieces even more valuable
back in Berlin florist matthias Bachchan
is hard at work over 23 million
Christmas trees are sold in Germany each
year most people favor classic
decorations many traditional trimmings
are symbolic Christmas ornaments are
actually supposed to evoke the Apple in
the story of Adam and Eve
tinsel is thought to represent angel
hair of the star at the top of the tree
is of course a reference to the Star of
Bethlehem there are always some new
trends with Christmas trees like
replacing them with a single abstract
branch any minimalist ornaments but in
recent years families and older
generations have come to appreciate the
romance of an old-fashioned tree they
remind us of our childhood and it would
be a shame if we stopped trimming them
they're lovely and symbolic it takes
three hours to get the tree sparkling
time now for Matias bottom to start
wrapping some gifts Christmas presents
were originally small enough to hang on
the tree but as they got bigger they
ended up under it
you